so dr dre is in the process of getting a
divorce from
his wife and she's asking for temporary
spousal support
and she asked for 2 million dollars a
month the judge asked her to break down
what the 2 million
would be and this is her list
clothes 135 laundry and cleaning
10 000 a month entertainment 900 000 a
month
charity 425 wait telephone cell phone
email 20 20 000 a month mortgage hundred
thousand a month
hey brad where the [ __ ] are you living
what also entertainment
900 000 wait what's what plan
is is that the 20 000 a month cell phone
plan what plan is that must be cricket
i mean what what what what are you
getting with the 20 000 a month plan
like
i have so many questions with all of
them okay the only one that makes sense
is the charity 125 grand where you're
like all right or
guess if you're really charitable yeah
and to me the only thing that makes
sense
is the education you live in california
if you have more than one kid
i don't know how many sixty sixty grand
a month you you
you know my kid goes to top private
school you would have to
you'd have to have four or five kids
right at least yeah
tuition and living expenses dude laundry
10 grand
yeah cool the judging can look this way
get the [ __ ] out but let me ask you this
doesn't mortgage anybody
deserve two million a month in support
okay but it so for me it all depends
were you there with me when it started
when we were coming up like so say i
went to law school
but my wife supported me when i was in
law school and then i got like to make
sure you had a house and [ __ ]
but she worked while i was in law school
so the only reason i'm a lawyer
and could do that is because she worked
took care of the house
took care of me made the money i
couldn't make any money right sure
then you go on and become a lawyer and
make a [ __ ] ton of money
i do believe she's entitled because
you're not where she is
but let's say let's say we're we get
married in college yeah i'm a first
round draft pick i get drafted
i go off and play yeah and then five
years down the road
you know i get my sunburst five years
down the road you want two million a
month
you weren't in the gym shooting with me
[ __ ] i agree with you 100
here's what i think i think if you have
kids
they should not they should not be
penalized so they should be able to keep
at least kind of quality of the life
because you shouldn't be
you shouldn't be like well dad's place
is so much better i never want to go
there
i never want to go to mom's place right
here's but that's what that's what
they're doing it's you got to maintain
the lifestyle right
so we might have two million we're
making fun of this but
you know he's a billionaire so in their
lifestyle might this might be
their norm where we see this like holy
[ __ ]
but she's like nah [ __ ] this is my life
dude like we gotta maintain this but
lifestyle to me makes sense so say
i don't know where you live but if your
mortgage is 100 grand i don't
i can't imagine a mortgage at a hundred
grand a month
like what is the the house must be
apparently she's currently living in
their shared home in malibu i don't know
if that
there's no way you're estimating what to
even at least like a hundred grand
there i there's a place in my
neighborhood that's renting renting
for 37 000 a month there's a place in
malibu in the summer that will rent for
like 85 years but you're talking about
creme de la creme
on the beach when they're billionaires
it's just a different
life so this is normal to her
but when you break it down like that you
look like an [ __ ] yep
you look like an [ __ ] did you if you
say to me
hey i want 1.9 a month because my kids
are used to
living this way i'm used to living this
way
this seems but when you break it down
and you say hey
i need 20 000 a month for my cell phone
forget all that
could you chill out on the 900 grand i
know yeah yeah
i can't get old how could could you
spend so say i'm like i'm gonna give you
900 you have to spend 900 thousand
dollars a month
on entertainment we're playing yeah i
can spend it because we're flying first
class everywhere
okay not first not first class we're
flying private
private's expensive dude but does that
fall under entertainment i guess oh yeah
so so you say you want to pick you want
to take me and then
three and a squad to miami for a show
okay what's the
private plan going to cost you probably
is it that much well you could do like
the least thing which i'm not doing
right my man is dr drake so you could do
like the least thing
but that's like 40 g's but 120 gets you
a [ __ ]
g ass private yeah
i guess i guess dude i guess because you
would have to try
i would have to literally at the
beginning of every month if you said
here's
here's nine hundred thousand dollars you
have to spend on entertainment
so yeah so what i say 40. new york city
to miami though
20 grand one way dude you would have to
fly private
all but that's all she knows dude you
gotta maintain my lifestyle
but but but if you're if you're spending
nine hundred thousand entertainment
what do you need a hundred thousand for
a mortgage you're never home
because you have to go do [ __ ] for the
nine unless unless you're hiring i'm
gonna hire john mayer to come over and
cook my dinner
yeah like you know what they're doing
she's shooting for the moon hopefully
land on the stars and get like a million
if you
it's insane if you were married to dr
dre
yeah or say you're married to the bridge
like a real rich woman
and you're gonna hit me like you did his
previous wife uh man is it worth two
million for dude you can hit me
you can beat me around
i think for two mil you can slap me
around i'm taking a punch for two
minutes i'll slap you you can stop
yeah i don't mind yeah i don't know i'll
take a spank to the ass yeah whatever
you want
mr dre but what what well like it
what are you asking what do you what
like are you getting
a million of it but it's just all
perspective yeah like i'm sure if we
broke down your monthly bills you break
down my monthly bills
nowhere near this but to a certain
people they're like what the [ __ ] you
spend that on
shoes yeah or you know whatever it is
like you spend on post baits like yeah
dude that's true
it's just it's all like there's certain
levels man but this is this is insane
either way she's so blind
to just what's happening in america
right now but but
not to defend her but to her perspective
like she came with dr dre he's a
straight-up billionaire yeah
so she's like this ain't [ __ ] dude is
two million a month
anything to a billionaire that's 24
million a year
what's what's 24 million percentage-wise
to a billion well
billion point 200 hundred millions right
it's so much money no it's like a
thousand it's a thousand something
million right a billion a billion is a
hundred
wait 100 million so a billion is a
right it's one thousand million one
thousand so that's just
this that doesn't do anything 24 million
i mean
that kind of money to me is not even it
it doesn't compute
which is everything's free so to to that
like like
class isn't a factor i think if i had a
billion dollars
i don't think there's any doubt that
everybody
that shares my last name would be set up
everyone no you're right there's a
couple people there
a couple people yeah but most people set
up
but i think i would have so much fun you
know one of the things that puma did for
me
be which i love one of my favorite
things to do you give it a billion
dollars no i wish
but they used to give me all these shoes
and and they would say drive around la
because i would say can i drive around
la and just hand them out to people and
they were like yeah that sounds like a
lot of fun just filming that's cool so
we would drive around we'd find people
who obviously live in wherever and we'd
handle my shoes if i had a billion
dollars
i would do that with money really a
hundred percent get robbed but you
probably
hire security i mean i'm i'm going
around with something now you know
they're selling those pumas for
meth right that's fine yeah whatever i
mean you know
except there were some people who's
legit crying
there were guys i was like what size
shoe are you and i remember when i
walked up this one guy i'm like what's
that shoe you
and he goes eight to ten and i was like
what he goes well i'm a size 10
but i can squeeze into a size eight if
they're new
and i said what are you wearing right
now he said eight and
his toes dude jam-packed and when i i
was like here's a size
size 10 and he wouldn't take him he was
like what
what does that mean like what do i have
to i'm not gonna suck you off yeah well
i have to do i'm like no these are free
shoes
and he was like i haven't worn a pair of
shoes that were my size
and i can't remember and he put him on
he you know what he did too which was
run off
he he ran like they made remember when
you used to put on new shoes and you
were yeah you're like yeah
yeah yeah yeah he ran up and down in
front of ralph's a couple times he's
like these feel good i'm like all right
dude check
chill out chill out yeah but yeah dude
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son